right
have you seen this diagram before this
particular diagram
does anyone know what the name of this
is
yeah um so it's supposed to make user
interfaces very easy right instead of
model view controller
you have actions and dispatcher and
action creators and and
store and views and view controls and
some other stuff
right so what about this diagram do you
recognize this
it's supposed to make event driven
programs somehow you know composable
or observable and finally now you have
propagation of change i mean what what
does that mean
and this thing here now that you know we
have different patch and sort of virtual
data
structures finally uis are declarative
right of
obviously so virtual becomes declarative
i mean why
this is the state of javascript in 2015.
like what happened here you know are we
over
engineering our apps or how we actually
found a better way of building stuff
and if it's better then why is there so
much to learn i mean why is
why why isn't better simpler and why
isn't better sort of like
more obvious for us
that over there is a sunflower and the
the center part of the sunflower
has these seeds that form this beautiful
pattern which is actually governed by
the golden ratio so think about the
golden ration for a while
1.618033 etc
sounds like an arbitrary sort of made-up
number
but actually occurs in nature and it
creates these things like this
so what if there would be something like
this for javascript so
a pattern which is natural it just
happens to be
there but it's still sort of beautiful
and complex and
you can't understand it
so i've been studying how to apply
reactive and functional programming for
user interfaces
and i stumbled upon this interesting
architecture which i want to
share with you today
have you tried already virtual reality
so first time i tried it there was this
demo scene you just see the table and
some objects
on the table and the first thing you you
feel is like i want to touch this and
it's it's it's kind of so engaging as
like your favorite single player
campaign game where
it's not a story it's not a movie it's
real interaction you feel like you're
there
so why does this happen what is going on
here
so this is called user no sorry human
computer interaction
so like a conversation is both parties
listen
and speak so if we zoom into the
computer what will we see well this the
desktop tower or the processing unit
and in between we have this thing called
interface which is normally comprised of
the
screen and the mouse and the keyboard
these kind of things
now notice there's the cycle structure
where information is inside the computer
it goes onto the screen
you see that with your eyes and you
decide to do something with your hands
on the mouse and keyboard
that triggers another change to the
computer and that generates another
screen and it keeps on going
so all user interfaces can be expressed
as
cycles this is our first insight when
we're trying to find a
interesting and natural architecture and
actually i challenge you to find a
ui that doesn't work on the low level as
a cycle
so in this system the interface devices
are often called
input device and output device
right the graphics you know graphics
output and that kind of stuff so
whenever you have an
input and an output what do you have in
between what is the best candidate
yeah a function right so x is
your mouse and your screen is f of x
so uis as functions so the computer's
role should just be a function right
whatever you put on the keyboard
and the screen should be your output as
a function
so remember the terminal programs that
sort of prompt for your input these were
blocking uis
so the computer will do nothing until
you do something
and modern uis are not like this anymore
instead
they are non-blocking so with this
autocomplete field
the computer is simultaneously
processing while
you are typing so there's no need to
sort of wait until the user end that
that just doesn't exist
so if we would draw these events
happening on timelines this is roughly
what we would see
the top tie line is what you input and
it runs in parallel to the bottom
timeline although the bottom timeline is
a function
of the top one there is no such idea as
weight or you know waits until the other
side stop
it stops and this so happens to be the
definition of asynchronous it's whenever
one side is allowed to con continue its
processing regardless of what the other
side is doing
so that's another one that uis are
asynchronous
by nature or should be we don't want
blocking your eyes what else so the
computer has all these
kind of devices to make um its interface
but what about
you as the user don't you have your
biological devices
for instance your eyes and your hands
right those are sort of your
devices one of them is part of your
senses and the other one is your
instrument of
expression now your devices are
connected to the computer's devices
right your your eyes are sort of
looking to the screen so but isn't the
computer um
doesn't it have also senses for instance
the mouse is how the computer senses the
outside world and
the computer's ears would be its
microphone
and also the computer screen is how the
computer sort of expresses its own
feelings or opinions right so there's a
symmetry here where both sides have
senses and both sides have expression
and that's another insight the uis are
symmetric with the user so the computer
symmetric with the user
and if they are symmetric then just as
the computer has an input device and
an output device so do you have an input
device your eyes
and an output device your hands
whenever you have an input and an output
what do you have in between
a function so now your brain is a
function
now this is a bit philosophical because
are you a referentially transparent
function
are you non-deterministic if you would
see the same screen
at the same time at the same place would
you do the same thing
now we don't really need to answer that
question we don't need to worry about
that
why because you don't have a time
machine you can't go back in the past
we cannot go and check if you would
actually do the same thing
so we can just assume that yeah let's
assume that you're going to do the same
thing if we would go back in time
so you are sort of deterministic
and this is what you do as a function
when you see jskoff put aside no jsc
budapest aside yeah
you emit some scroll events as your
output and you
see something interesting you click on
it so the input is what you see from the
computer
and the output is what you do with your
hands
so let's try to explore the final
insight that
the user could be a function as well
that's our we have now nice five
insights to build something but we have
sublime text open and all that was
interesting and nice
philosophy but how do we get coding some
actual javascript
so let's start with a relatively easy
one probably the smartest people in this
room can make a function that given
a string of the url renders as an
output the screen of the website
but it's not a function from a string to
a screen why because that would be a
blocking
function it would be you know we don't
want to do that so it's a function from
that weird arrow to this weird arrow so
what are these
arrow thingies well to me they kind of
look like
fruit skewers or you know
well yeah sorry so how could we express
these
food sticks in javascript well we have
the first cucumber
first tomato second cucumber etc these
are sequences so
we could probably use an array right
that's what javascript gives us
for basic sequences and
arrays in javascript has have these
functions sort of
map so here we are multiplying each item
by 10.
and we also have filter as a function
over arrays
which is kind of like removing an item
except we are creating a new
array instead of changing the previous
one
so it does look like our fruit skewers
could have this map function right i
don't see a big challenge in doing this
and they could easily also have a filter
function
but there is a big problem why uh
these things cannot be erased is because
of this arrow meaning time
right and these dots are just things
happening which is the definition of an
event
so our fruit sticks are kind of you know
event streams that's what they are
what's the difference with array
well an array is a sequence in space and
an event stream is basically a sequence
in time
and for sequences in time you can do
fancier things that arrays
cannot do for instance you can delay
each item by one second
and also event streams can be infinite
so there will always be the next hour
from now even if this planet stops
existing
while arrays have to be finite
and not just delay but you have many
other functions like merge and window
and combine latest and with latest from
and flatmap
so now we know that the computer
is not a function from a string to a
screen it's a function from an event
stream of string
to an event stream of screen
and we could name the top one as
interaction events is whatever you do as
a user
and the bottom one is screen events is
whatever the computer generates
so if we would write in javascript
actually typescript here just to show
the types
this is roughly how we would get started
and we just need to fill in
what happens inside that function so
all event streams have this listen
method which is really what you expect
it to be it's kind of like add event
listener for clicks so
no mystery on this part
now the user function will do the
opposite right as we saw
it will take the screen events as input
and it will generate
interaction events as output
but how can you write this in javascript
right we need your
we would need your brain for that so no
can do
so we can actually decompose the user
function into
smaller functions first this screen
event is rendered
is put to the dom and the dom with the
browser
shows that on the physical screen that
goes to your eyes and then
your eyes and the signal to your brain
and your brain takes some time deciding
what to do
and then finally you decide okay i'm
going to click that and that
triggers an event on the dawn event
dispatcher
so we only need to care about the
beginning and the end which is the dom
right the dom will be the ambassador
for our user or the proxy for our user
and the other functions are just living
in another world in javascript so
they're still part of our user function
but we don't have direct access to them
it's as if you know they were living on
some remote server
and we're using the dom as the client to
access that
so in javascript it would look like this
we first start with
this given screen event stream and we
can listen to each
screen event and render that to the dom
somehow
then we create an a plain empty event
stream
called interaction events which is what
we will return at the bottom of the
function
so then we listen to all possible events
happening on the dawn so this star
there doesn't actually exist it's just
to illustrate our idea
and this probably is not performing
either but just to show you that we can
write this function
and so we whatever we listen to anything
we just
forward that to interaction events
so and we're done so the user function
is written and we can also listen to
what it what it outputs
now if you put both function
applications together you
get this and now we have kind of like a
serious problem because
well if you can't see the problem i'm
going to rename these so it's easier to
see
can you see it now well
if we replace a with f of b on the
second line you get this
and now you can see the problem because
b is undefined on the right hand side
so we just can't do this it's because
this equals symbols
means assignment right that's where a
complication is coming from you can't
assign from think that it doesn't ex
you know yeah so we have other types of
equals in javascript
for instance double equals and triple
equals
so the equal symbols in mathematics
means an equation so what if we just
forget assignment
and think of an equation to solve this
this is actually a special type of
equation because it's a fixed point
that over there is the definition of a
fixed point
it's whenever x is f of x
and it's pretty common in mathematics
like the cosine has one
so what if our problem would be actually
to discover this
the event stream that satisfies this
equation
so let's forget assignment and instead
consider equality let's use mathematics
as an inspiration
so we're back into the dangerous
unmathematical world of javascript and
uh assignment will not help us here the
complication actually is that well the
second line doesn't have a problem at
all but the first line has a problem
because it needs to exist before we call
this
computer function so what if we just do
that like
with this line we declare interaction
events as an empty event stream what is
an empty event stream is just an empty
fruit skewer with nothing on it quite
uninteresting
and then now that it's available we can
call the computer function on it and we
get this
screen events as output naturally now
the screen events is available we can
apply the user function on it and we get
interaction events 2 a second one
so what have we just achieved with this
piece of code
well when we called the computer
function on an empty event stream we got
this
screen events which by the way starts
with this default screen why because
well
if you don't interact with the computer
at least you see this login screen
so and then now we apply the screen
events on the user and we got this
real interaction events coming from the
real user
but we have these two interaction events
so we just need to sort of copy paste
whatever happens on the bottom one back
into the first one
so with this whenever an event happens
on the second
it will be replicated back into the
first and then we have sort of closed
loop
so in javascript this would be actually
about listening to whatever happens on
the second and
just forwarding that to the first
and we can also simplify this code by
getting rid of intermediate variables so
this is not a scary operation
okay no magic and we can do that again
with screen events and we get this
so hopefully now you see something that
looks like a fixed point
right i mean you can compare b with
interaction events and you can compare g
of f
with a computer
and it's solved right it wasn't that
hard
after all but there's something that
still annoys me with this computer
function because in reality
it would be a huge function so
in a real javascript application this
would be thousands of lines of code
because it should do
networking and rendering and
calculations and whatnot so
how can we improve on this
so model view controller is older than i
am
so it's been around since the 70s and
80s
and this is the rough this is roughly
the same diagram from the 80s i
didn't really change this and there's
two things i really like about this
diagram and first of all
is the user so with all these fancy
architectures for user interfaces we
kind of forgot
where does the user plug in into our
system right
so i like it that that is here and we
should probably do this more often
the other thing that i like about this
diagram is that it almost looks like
that
cycle cycle diagram that we saw some
minutes ago
right except there's one big difference
is that there's no arrow from the mouse
to the screen while there is an arrow
from a
controller to a view
so mvc is not a perfect cycle and
we just can't name this mvc but it does
look like those could correspond to
model
view and user but then we don't know how
to name the mouse because it's the
complicated bit
it cannot be named controller
so do you know what was the original
idea in mvc in small talk forgetting all
these routes and back-ends and stuff
it was actually in their words to bridge
the gap between the digital information
of the computer
and the user's mental model that's what
they said
so the computer speaks bits zeros and
ones
and bytes and you speak english
hungarian and
cat pictures so that's what the view
does
right it translates from zeros and ones
to english and cat pictures right
if we're talking about two languages and
the view just should
just bridge that gap for you so why not
the other direction should just be
translating from cat pictures back into
something that the computer appreciates
right you're giving sort of
you're making a request to change
something in the computer and you're
giving that in sort of human terms
mouse and keyboard and whatnot so i call
this thing
intent but you can name it whatever else
you want
i just like this name because it means
an in an interpretation of what the user
is trying to achieve in the context of
the digital information so it turns out
this big massive computer function can
be decomposed into smaller functions
intent model and view where intent
translates the user's interactions the
model does the heavy lifting
and the view translated back to cat
pictures
and if you're not satisfied with this
with this decomposition
you can split it into two functions or
you can split it into six functions i
don't care
so these are just functions and as a
good programmer you should know when to
split a function whenever it gets too
big
right well this is roughly what my
framework called cycle.js does you can
find that in it in that
address up there and the event stream
that it uses
come from this library called rxjs a
reactive library
now what cycle just does is basically
solve some problems
with this code what we wrote some
minutes ago
first of all this is boilerplate we
don't want to write that
in every app and this is mutation and
it's also boilerplate we don't
want to write that every time in our
code and then we have two event streams
to
represent the same thing one of them is
the proxy and the other one is the real
when we
attach them to each other so if all all
of this mess
you just want to care about this part
right
you want to specify as a programmer how
does the computer work
in this user interface so
that's what cycle allows you to do is
just specify one function
and it does the rest of the loop for you
and this is the api basically two
functions actually
for this presentation we just need apply
to dom where we give there the computer
function
and we say where in in the dom will this
live so the container there
let's see wait how we can use this so
imagine a hello basic hello world
program where
there's this one big input field where
you insert the name and the
header just greets the name let's try to
encode this quickly
so we can call apply to dom giving id
app as a pointer to where on the dom
should our app live
and the computer function as the second
parameter
if you call interactions.get you it will
return you an event stream so you give
dot field as a selector and input as the
vent type
so this will this will return us the
event stream of
input events on the dot field element
so we don't have that yet but you're
going to see it soon and i call this
change name dollar sign and dollar sign
is just a convention to say that this is
an event stream you don't really need it
so name stream will represent the actual
data that we will display
so it needs to have an an initial value
so we just choose empty string
otherwise it just takes everything that
comes from change name stream
and then we convert name stream into
screen stream
by mapping every name to a div that
displays this data
so notice now that we have this uh input
element with class name field
and now it makes sense how this will
work because with the first line there
it's after all a cycle right and then we
just return
at the bottom screen stream we can also
rearrange this code by
doing something which is not magical
don't be scared
and we get this so just rearranging so
literally what the key
what the computer does is translate from
keyboard
to screen you can clearly see that in
this function
it gets interactions events
from the keyboard and it generates the
screen
so remember that of course we can
refactor this computer function to
smaller functions composition of intent
model and view so how would it look like
if we would split it like this
well first of all the intent would take
care of
interpreting whatever the user is trying
to do and this function just wraps those
two parts that we're doing so
whenever we get an event of input on
that field
we just get what is the value inside
that element
and then the model takes care of
of taking whatever happens on change
name stream from the intent
and just make sure that it starts with
some initial data
then the view converts the model's name
stream into these divs
and finally the computer is just a
function composition of these three
so you choose you can either do it like
this or you can do it like that or like
this it's up to you as the programmer
so what have we just made here model
view user and intent
are functions and between each of them
is an event stream
so name stream is the output of the
model and the input of the view
and screen stream is the output of the
view and the input and
of the user and so forth and guess what
you know this is unidirectional data
flow
and this thing here was functional
programming
and immutable techniques
and these food sticks were you know
reactive programming
that's another name you can give to
react to programming other than regular
programming
food sticks that and the divs that the
view creates
they are using the virtual dom
so it turns out that not all of these
concepts were that scary after all right
i mean
we saw that most of most of these
actually just emerged naturally from
those
in insights that we got from user
interfaces
oh and hey one last thing remember
the human computer interaction what
happens if we
replace the computer with another human
i mean if the computer has senses and
expression can't we just replace the
computer with anything that has senses
and expression so what if this
model here can actually represent any
kind of interaction whether it's
computer and a human or it's a
human and a human or it's a computer in
a computer et cetera
so in an interaction with another human
you
take um input words with your ears and
output words with your mouth right
so when alice hears her friend bob
saying what's up
she processes that in her brain and she
outputs
her answer the event stream of alice's
words is her part in the interaction and
then when bob
takes alice's words as input he also
makes an answer
so it turns out that alice's words are
an event stream as a fixed point of the
composition of alice brain with bob's
brain
so if we merge alice's words with bob's
words we get an event streams
of words from both of them which is what
you know we normal humans name is just
a conversation thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
let's have a sit on this awesome awesome
seat so from what i've noticed there
were no questions
on twitter i'm a little bit disappointed
but um we have someone with a mic
so if there are any questions for the
audience anyone
i can't see anyone seriously
any oh there's a question over there
awesome
okay thank you for your interesting
presentation
and you wrote some markup
in the javascript uh does this framework
or something
use react or something different
yeah um is this mic still yeah um yes
it actually doesn't use react it uses
virtual dom
virtual dash don that's the name of the
library basically because i want to get
the different patch algorithms
and and i want to use them in the
framework so react doesn't provide that
but on the other hand the community
around cyclejs just made this
cycle dash react which where you can use
react there and also the the markup you
can use jsx with cycle
but normally i use this virtual
hyperscript it's just an age
function but you could use jsx as well
thank you any more questions
yay
hi last time i saw sanctuary
a yes github page is under development
is this yet or production
ready now um yeah so
this is not production ready because
actually
i'm redesigning it quite a lot like so
the first version i made was
had a completely different api than this
and if you would build a production api
production app on that it would have you
know
been like angular 2 but instead of that
effect it would be angular 3
4 5 6 and 7. so
because this is really new stuff and
sometimes you just really
get it that okay this is like i need to
remake this because i actually
discovered that i need to do this
better but finally now i think we're
converging to a very nice api i don't
think i can get
nicer than this so soon and enough
i think maybe you know a couple of i
can't promise anything but you know
yeah thank you thank you uh
we still have some time so maybe another
question there it is
see you won't ask questions why won't
you ask questions on twitter
no internet that's true
hello thank you for your presentation uh
how to handle errors in this
reactive pattern should i put errors on
the
same in screen stream or
for example on that conversation between
alice
the errors should go to the same stream
or some
individual stream yeah so rxjs this
library for
event streams it has these uh error
handling operators already for yourself
and
when you watch matt's presentation about
rx he's going to explain it
completely you're going to see that yes
you can handle arrows here so
it's really not a mystery but i'll leave
the all the details to him because
you're going to see
the presentations quite nice but yeah
you can handle errors and it's just not
a problem
thanks okay one more
so many questions then
hi so if you're thinking about this
small little apps that you showed they
are easy to comprehend in cycles
but what if you have like a web store or
something like that would you
want to do sep or several of these
little cycles or would you want to
make a really large app that somehow
just merges
all the different
cycles together yeah so um when i showed
the api there were these two functions
one of them was applied to dawn and the
other one was register custom element
and the other one the second one we
didn't use and
that basically creates kind of
components of
you know react style so you can build uh
components with cycle and the components
are also
specified just like the computer
function was so it's also
so you could think of the components as
cycles also so they're kind of
mini programs so yeah and
so basically the tools for building
building very large apps are
components react style and also
just you know decomposing your function
into smaller bits
and yeah okay cool
thanks bobby good awesome um
we have another speaker um one more
round of applause please
you